[Music]
i don't want to talk to you anymore
that's gnarly i mean that's like
hot what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we close out season 17 with josh
brolin he's an academy award-nominated
actor whose storied credits include no
country for old men sicario milk
deadpool the avengers and many many more
his latest project though is the mind
bending mystery thriller outer range
which is set to release on prime video
april 15th josh brolin welcome to the
show thank you brother how are you
around hot sauce before we dig in i mean
i've been around hot sauce my whole life
i said earlier that my mom's from texas
my dad is a big hot sauce aficionado
i'm just kind of a trashy tabasco guy
but you know i'm willing
but i'm interested to volley with you i
want to see how this goes and i've been
on kind of a diet you know i got to get
ready for dune and a week ago i kind of
went into panic mode so i stopped eating
all the stuff that i was eating so we're
dealing with this on kind of an empty
stomach which i think might
make for an interesting
moment
[Music]
right on
this is like a miyagi thing yeah here we
go
set the tone ready
do you always use the same sauces
so every season we're out with the old
in with the new so this is the season
finale for season 17. so you've had
these sauces all season all season but
this is the last time that they'll be on
this table right on sending them off in
style
[Music]
that's really good man
so your new series outer range is a
mind-blowing western set mystery
thriller in which you play a hard-nosed
rancher who discovers this large
metaphysical black hole on his property
i've heard you mention a natural draw to
the absurd to the weird what is it that
sold you on the story of royal abbott
i mean exactly that anything that kind
of hybrids
something that i'm interested in which
would be westerns but then if i go back
to when i was a kid and i you know got
exposed to literature reading for the
first time you know i grew up on a ranch
and then i remember
reading ray bradbury's books or isaac
asimov's books which really contrasted
my reality
and it was all interesting to me i
always loved that kind of uh [ __ ]
with the alchemy so this was a great
opportunity to be able to mesh something
that was instigated my childhood in a
really really positive amazing way and
then what you get is this kind of
behavioral
chaos of humans dealing with something
that's outside of themselves or what
they consider unknown
[Music]
dawson's cedar i'm already getting weird
i hear my friend liz laughing already
and nothing's even happened yeah
dangerous she knows she knows a lot more
than i do
so recently released the art and soul of
dune a book that pairs your writing
along with photos from dunes director
photography greg fraser who by the way
shout out recently won an academy award
here at the oscars
what are the conversations like between
actors and cinematographers on set like
how does blocking or lens choice help
inform your approach to a scene
it's really amazing to be able to work
with people who are
very good skilled and experienced at
what they do it's actually really fun
because
the switch happens almost
instantaneously where you can be [ __ ]
around with somebody
and then all of a sudden you're like
look the lights hitting there
i know that
you perceived a scene in a certain way
and yet i come in with my own ideas and
how we can collaborate which can be
it can be the most awful experience if
you're collaborating with people who
wanted are just interested in putting
their kind of power stamp on it but
people like greg people like denis
actors like javier actors like rebecca
ferguson it's a very kind of loose very
humble place
let's eat another [ __ ] thing
i don't care about cinematographers
right now man
what are we doing this is like cocaine i
feel weird
right in this weird room together i
don't know what cocaine feels like but
yeah let's just go with it
all right so this next one
anyway on that note this next one is the
calabria
oh
pure uncut calabria that's that's
beautifully put
thank you for running with that
[Music]
you know when you eat beets and you go
to the bathroom and you think
something's gone wrong and you look in
the toilet and you think you might have
to call 9-1-1 yeah what happens to you
when you go to the bathroom after you
eat these so for me i think the biology
has more or less adjusted at this point
you know to where i can kind of go
through life without much of a problem
for you tomorrow though
yes
chapters like anything can happen
if i film it will you cut it into the
show sure yeah it can be the bonus scene
you know close out season 17 with a bang
is it true that you blew the audition
for the fly too by over committing to
the metamorphosis problem how do you
know this that's cool
that's fishing i like when that happens
yeah committing to the metamorphosis
riding on the ground foaming from the
mouth it was it was the fly too and i
went in there man and i totally
committed and i did this for like 22
years with pretty much every audition i
ever did but i i was on the ground and i
was frothing at the mouth because he's
in a chrysalis he's in a cocoon like
right what happens to one that's human
that's not used to something
like morphing from one thing to another
one would imagine that it would be a
painful process would one not
and then you finish the audition which
is always the most uncomfortable part
where they all look at you and there's a
pause and they go
thanks for coming in
thank you that was wonderful thank you
and i go is there anything else you want
me to do or if i can do it with you know
if that that wasn't appropriate there's
another way we can deal with it
and they go no that was fine that was
great
and then i left and i got back to my
place and there was already a message
from my agent and i called the agent
back and he said what the [ __ ] did you
do in there
literally verbatim
and i said did i get it
and he's like oh no
like they'll probably never see you
again i was like well i still don't
understand to this day i was like don't
you want somebody who commits
anyway
i didn't i didn't do that part
i didn't do that part
yeah this is hotter
i i feel that one man
we're climbing
so that's number four
number four
if i itch my ears my ear gonna hurt
later yeah you know what actually that's
a good question because there is some
sort of like you know cross-pollination
that goes on but what you really have to
look out for is your eyes you know don't
rub your eyes don't rub your eyes there
that's a wow
the ingenuity here
that's what you get when you're dealing
with really smart people
so in addition to starting wall street
money never sleeps i know that you
worked for years as a real life day
trader specializing in pullbacks off the
top of your head without thinking about
it too much what do you think is the
greatest stock market movie of all time
oh wall street i mean of course man i
mean that's what others are there i mean
there are there are wall street you have
wolf of wall street is a great movie i
mean i knew i knew
jordan belford for a while and and i
still
i talked to him once every couple of
years now but
i mean that's an incredible story man
that's an incredible story but that's
not if that's about stocks but it's not
about stocks wall street is about
trading
in the behavior around trading whereas
wolf of wall street is just about
absolute you know unadulterated greed
which is kind of amazing in itself i
thought that was a phenomenal movie
there was one point where i thought i
was going to be in
a version of that movie but i think kyle
chandler ended up doing what we had
talked about and i thought he was
excellent excellent amazing
yeah i don't feel like so anything
biologically has changed yet do you know
what i mean i'm not sweating i'm not not
doing like a matt damon where i look
like i'm gonna fall off my chair
[Laughter]
[Music]
los calientes mm-hmm
huh yeah that's really good man so far i
feel like we're five for five
five for five i'm stoked
i thought i was gonna have to eat bread
before just so i didn't ship my i mean
so i didn't throw up
but
i feel good right now the whole milk
thing is not really becoming an issue
even water
you're crushing it
yeah thanks this is really fun i mean i
i love this this is great
i'm getting
all right josh we have a recruiting
segment on our show called explain that
grammar we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll pull the
picture up over here on the monitor and
then you just tell us the bigger story
okay
can you pull back the curtain on the
movie magic that's going on in the
makeup chair here is that from deadpool
2 yeah so the whole
so i've had that done a few times and
when you have that done
they put it on you and it slowly
obviously slowly solidifies right and as
it slowly solidifies because it's around
everything and they've created holes in
your nose
other than the holes in your nose
everything starts to muffle so you lose
the pores start popping and you start to
lose all sense of sounds or obviously
sight and all that kind of stuff so the
sight thing is one thing and then when
you start losing sound
it starts to become a little freaky and
some people can't do this but i have to
i've learned that i have to have a pad
and then what i wrote on that pad at
some point during that process was
mild panic
and then they get really close to your
ear and they're like it's okay dude
you're doing great we only have this
long left and then they sit there and
they basically hold your hand through
the process because you have no sense of
anything there's no sense of space
vicinity or proximity
sounds anything you lose it all it's a
wonderful experiment but it's can be
terrifying why would one want to do that
but you know when you're doing deadpool
2 you're excited at that point you
really don't know what you're getting
into so you're like okay [ __ ] it i'll do
it
well speaking of doing things that make
you ask yourself why would anyone do
that are you ready to move on yes to the
back half yeah
so this is the queen majesty coco ghost
coco ghost
do you think i curse too much no okay
you're such a clean guy
what does that mean you just feel very
clean to me
you just feel like you just showered or
just groomed
well either maybe that's just like the
who's your groomer
me just it's a solo mission i'm just
joking
shout out to susan dude i love that
this is me man
yeah
i've never felt as clean as you look
[Laughter]
what's special to you about the jiva
theater center in rochester it seems
like that literally the greatest
questions i've ever been asked seriously
like i'm i'm blown away by i don't know
who's working for you but
don't fire him
um
jiva theater was run by howard millman
but there was
a classic portion and then a new plays
portion
of that year
that anthony zerby ran and anthony zurby
is an integral part of my life somebody
who i met doing a
western show called the young riders
amazing shakespearean actor an amazing
friend
my officiant my wedding but it was an
incredible four years of my life where i
did i would do two plays in rotating rap
and sometimes do a classic piece
but i was always doing two plays at once
so that was kind of a
confu what would seem to be confusing
but it was actually a really
great skill to be able to pop in and out
of something or do one thing in the
afternoon and then go do a completely
different character at night
and i worked some amazing actors and
and uh yeah so it was a great experience
and i think if there's any kind of
modicum of a perception of me being a
character actor i think that's kind of
where it
was revealed
through anthony's irby you know
[Music]
you just brought back something that was
really cool to me so i'm sorry let's
fire it up man
yeah man this is interesting
i'm starting to
i'm starting to feel
like there's something wrong with me
[Laughter]
because i've always felt that way but
now particularly because you're just
running through these hot sauces just
crushing these sauces it's not that i'm
crushing them that's not how i would put
it but i would i would say that there's
nothing well there you go yeah there's a
little moment
there's nothing that has
worried me
that's real
[Music]
that's good actually that's super good
and worth the little
[Music]
all right
yeah that's real man
so i'm fascinated by your stories about
working with the coen brothers
for example you know sending off audio
voices that you're doing for hail caesar
and then getting feedback like the ps
sound really good but the h's aren't
great so maybe work on the h's
when you think of all the enigmatic
notes that they've given you over the
years is there one that stands out as
the most quintessentially cohen brothers
um when we were doing no country you
know everything was pretty much drawn
and you kind of knew what you were doing
and it was it was not dialogue heavy so
there wasn't a lot of stuff to
experiment with and change
but i know when i got the the satchel
and i opened it up i said don't you
think he should say something he looks
at the dead guy and then he looks around
and
you know you can tell he's thinking
about what is this what do i want to do
with this and shouldn't there be like a
little something there and and and joel
goes well like what
and
i said i don't know like a huh or like a
hmm
and they go
is there anything else and i go
like
and they go
what else
and then now you're thinking
they're [ __ ] with me right
so i went through about six of them and
they go and ethan said try the second
one
so i did the second one
whatever's in there and then every time
we screen the movie once the movie was
finished i always knew where ethan was
in the theater because every time that
moment happened he would burst out
laughing
so was it a joke or did it help the
movie in the scene
we'll never know
we'll never know
any kind of film that they've come out
with and they've manifested that's good
is an accident oh yeah yeah just a
coincidence that every time every time
make one
not because of skill or anything
all right all right man it's happening
bro it is it is it's actually finally
finally
at long last
yeah and just in time my ears are
ringing it's not okay
for the next wing which is the bomb
beyond insanity
the bomb beyond insanity
[Music]
my teeth are reacting right now
yeah
like just crushing that wing
this is a great example of how i've
dealt with my life and why i am the way
i am
committing
yeah but it's stupidity
has anybody ever thrown up
no
no we're in the clear
why do you think you might be breaking
the ground uh i don't know maybe have
you have you ever
not so funny i've seen you do this
because i watched your show
i'll yeah
oh wow
wow
so why did you drink the milk what's the
difference between the milk and oh god
damn it's odd dude
so the milk [ __ ] gnarly yeah
crazy hot sauce
the milk is sort of a temporary relief
but i don't think like anything helps
like we're just in the soup now
i don't want to talk to you anymore
[Laughter]
that's gnarly i mean that's like a hot
hot
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh things are starting to run and bleed
it's crazy
is that really the i don't know what to
do with myself
i understand the struggle yeah
wow man stretch it out
do you still love me i still love you i
love you even more i love you even more
i might ask you to spoon me in a second
whatever you need whatever you need to
get through it
whatever it's when you breathe it it's
hard kind of reactivates right yeah yeah
what did you learn
sneaking out to go to the punk rock club
godzilla's as a teenager like what do
you think you learned about yourself
i don't know how you know this man
you're freaking me out
be careful
don't manipulate me
going down to godzilla's just as black
flag and circle jerks and dead kennedys
all those guys were starting to come in
was the it would be like the equivalent
of cbgb's back in the day
and it was just crazy man you just see i
mean it was like it was performance art
and again like reading
ray bradbury and isaac asimov back in
the day when i was a kid that was like
the next level and next milestone of
that
i was like this is this is a totally
different existence and one that i
understand a lot better than the one
that's in front of me
yeah man nailed the dismount
thank you
are you ready to move on to the next
wing this is the pucker butt pepper
company
seriously yeah
or did you just make that up no oh
that's pitching
that's cool
the pup pucker butt pepper company
funky that is okay here we go
ready i'm ready
[Music]
and going in on those wings well dude if
you're gonna do it i love them do it i
love that
wow man
we're almost there we are almost done
we're good
it's all good you know when somebody
says it's all good that there's
panic time it is panic time oh it's all
good man okay can you speak to
obsessively baking pies on the set of
labor day your your co-star kate winslet
she has a quote where she'd say he'd
give pies to everyone it really was
exciting at first but later on you'd see
a pie and go running what's the key to
getting that like flaky crust
oh there was something about how you
indent i remember i was taught how to
indent the crust
and how it would cook but i also there
was something about my oven wasn't
working like other ovens or it was an
older house
and and it and it actually worked
because it was a slower cook and it
created a harder crust than usual so i
made an even better pie by accident than
i probably would have made had i had the
proper
oven
god i talk a lot man you had that magic
oven you had that magic i did i did
[Music]
what's your favorite show
oh
like of all time or like right now i
would say both i said it's two separate
moments but what's your favorite show of
all time
where i was in my life and the the
stretch that it gave to me maybe south
park oh wow yeah
and then without thinking about it too
much uh currently i would say uh
succession oh really is kind of the
thing that i'm i'm locked into or no
we're you know anticipating that my wife
got me into succession it's very very
good
what about you favorite all time that's
tough right
under these circumstances laverne and
shirley there we go let's go for this
when fonzie was in the air and you
didn't know whether he was gonna make
the jump or not
let's see if we make it okay
i actually kind of saturated that yeah
well
this is a commitment here
like the fly to audition but then the
double dip chicken talk show form wow
yeah no no no sometimes it's like you do
this anyway where you just swallowed the
wrong way but if you swallow hot sauce
the wrong way it just it's not
but i stopped it different ball game
altogether you know there's a time we
had uh colin farrell in here earlier
this season
and i had like where i inhaled and like
i feel like just it was just like a
straight pepper like just a straight
thing
right to the throat
yeah yeah and just couldn't talk i saw
that i don't know if it was the moment
with him but i saw you have a moment
where you couldn't talk very well oh
with uh john bernthal maybe that that's
who it was
i legit choked
yeah like oh you actually choked on the
chicken like a little piece of chicken
every chocolate you choked your chicken
[Laughter]
but literally on that episode i took
like a deep breath in and i've never had
that before when like
like vacuum sealed into the windpipe and
then i'm doing it in the bizarre context
of this show yeah and then i thought i
was just gonna die on my show yeah yeah
but you know what
made it through you should be very proud
of i mean this show and like i said the
reaction of so many people
when i brought when i bring up your show
is is a massive like it's not like oh
yeah i've seen i love that show it's
like no [ __ ] way you're gonna be on
that show it's like a major reaction but
was there a moment when you were choking
on your chicken
that you felt i can't die on hot ones
you know what that's lame
i have to even though i'm not saying
it's not it's not yeah like insult your
show at all no no but i know what you're
saying right because it goes uh one of
two ways you know what i mean where
maybe it's almost like oh well this is
me dying on my shield you know what i
mean like if i go down a chicken wing
talk show host goes down choking on a
wing yeah it's kind of cool it's kind of
cool it's kind of cool it's kind of like
that right about you know what i mean
yeah exactly like i think that's how
like
the legacy kind of lives
on purpose right and then they could
ever within you
anything beyond this was kind of going
to be not as
kind of you know grab public attention
like but then i'd never have to face
that reality because all right
at the peak
i just went down in flames and there
it is
like the armpit lick
re-lift here
josh
roland
taking on every single sauce in a lick
that's how i think you put an
exclamation point on season 17 and look
at you taking on the wings of death
living to tell the tale and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
what i have going on in my life what i
have going on right now is total chaos
and insanity inside my mouth
i mean isn't that the point um
i have outer range
where i lick the palette of absurdity
at a range we have coming out april 15th
and i'm very proud of it it was a lot of
hard work it was in horrible elements
when you go through that you want the
result you want to be good and i think
we come up we came up with something
very interesting and original so i hope
you guys enjoy
it that was so much fun dude that was so
much fun you're not just saying that i
don't ever want to do night time talk
shows again this is like
this is what i've been talking about
like do we have to break an egg on my
head like i don't understand what that
has to do with the movie no yeah i
understand hot chicken wings that's cool
that's cool
thank you brother
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans and they said we were
crazy they said we were nuts a hot sauce
for kids they said it wouldn't it
shouldn't be done well guess what we did
it anyway and now we're doubling down we
started with the green say hello to hot
ones junior the yellow
the yellow is a super mild hot sauce
with sweet tropical heat from mango
pineapple and scotch bonnet pepper
whether you're a parent child or just
want a super mild sauce this is the
sauce for you and if you want to be the
first person to try it the april hot one
subscription box is where you'll find it
sign up by april 15th
heatness.comheatness.com.com
to sign up and order
the yellow